while the unanswered questions keep
coming about Prince Andrew's
relationship with Jeffrey Epstein the
Duke of York's been taking time out
among Europe's money the elite with his
ex-wife Sarah Ferguson in sort of grande
Sarah's been here 11 or 12 years she's
almost always here and she she pretty
much I'd say nine times out of 10 gives
out the prizes she actually gives out
gives up the gold medal at the par yeah
we know the couple flew into Spain last
week as we toured the secluded lanes
where some of the grandest estates are
hidden in the hillsides trying to find
them it became clearer that they were
still here
I think it's behind there we met an
Argentine woman who told us she had
provided there dinner on Sunday night
she said in last night she cooked with
her husband their family cook to what
they call an asado which is a big kind
of meal barbecue huge sort of meaty
barbecue at private birthday party a
50th birthday pie for a friend of theirs
at which Fergie and Andrew attended last
night earlier in this day the staff here
at this exclusive restaurant told us
that the prince and Sarah Ferguson came
to eat in a specially cordoned off area
but not until their security team had
swept the entire restaurant and checked
it was safe this video of Jeffrey
Epstein following his conviction for
having sex with underage girls shows not
only the pedophile financier but also
his house guest at his Manhattan mansion
peering around the front door a picture
taken at Gillen Maxwell's house in
London in 2001 shows Prince Andrew with
his arm around the waist of Virginia
Roberts who was then 17 she alleges she
had sex with a Duke on three occasions
Buckingham Palace has strenuously denied
that Andrew had any form of sexual
contact or relationship with Miss
Roberts Prince Andrew and Virginia
Roberts are believed to have been in or
around the same location on three
occasions in 2001 the Daily Mail is
published what appear to be the
right records of Jeffrey Eckstein's
private jet they show Virginia Roberts
was in London in March when the picture
with the prince was taken Epstein and
Roberts then traveled to New York in
April where the Duke was starting an
official visit to the United States and
finally the jet took the financier and
teenage girl to Epstein's private island
a few days later
Prince Andrew was a short flight away in
the Bahamas on holiday how long the Duke
is planning to stay here in the wealthy
enclave in the Sun is unclear well is as
clear as the glistening sea of Sauter
Grande is the questions about his time
with Jeffrey Epstein will still be
waiting when he gets home
Gary Bowden Sky News in southern Spain